after session I'm just filling in here
for the person's speaker from computer
science insolence one of the world's
experts in distributed computing and
it's very fortunate that Mexico
interested in networks of sparking ones
okay so this is our work on an
algorithmic theory of brain networks and
I know everybody here is from
neuroscience so please don't get too
upset if I say something wrong about the
neuroscience I am a computer scientist
and mathematician
okay so background so I work in the
field of distributed algorithms so I
have a research group that works on
algorithms so what's that well typically
it's concerned with communicating in
wired networks wireless networks
organizing networks doing distributed
data management solving problems of
consensus and decision making problems
etc another aspect of what we do is
falls under a topic that we could call
general concurrent systems theory which
is concerned basically with modeling
systems and then proving theorems about
how they how you can construct them and
why they work okay so we observe that
many kinds of biological systems are
essentially distributed algorithms so
for example cells in developing
organisms they organize themselves no
central control but they organize
themselves into patterns insect colonies
another topic we've we've worked on they
cooperate to solve problems of exploring
for food allocating themselves to the
many different tasks that the colony has
to perform and reaching consensus for
example on where their nests should be
located and of interest to this audience
neurons cooperate to implement problems
of focus learning memory
compared to general distributed
algorithms the ones that arise in
biology have certain characteristics
they use simple means of communication
with chemical messages not you know
arbitrarily complex messages from some
message alphabet the components
typically have simple state now I don't
know how exactly how simple you might
say neuron state is it's probably more
complicated than the models are
describing right now an important
characteristic is that the algorithms
that occur in biology have to be very
flexible work in different under
different conditions robust to when some
things go wrong and adaptive to changes
this is for some background this is not
typically what we worry about for
distributed algorithms
at least we don't emphasize it as much
there's too much emphasis maybe on just
getting the most efficient algorithms
okay so to study biological distributed
algorithms which has now become a field
it has a workshop that's me held now for
the sixth time and we ask questions like
how can distributed algorithms help in
understanding the behavior of biological
systems or how can the methods of
distributed algorithms help us in
modeling and analyzing biological
systems but on the in the other
direction maybe it helps to understand
biological systems maybe that will help
us in building better distributed
network algorithms or as we've seen at
this workshop better algorithms of other
kinds like machine learning algorithms
some of what we've worked on I mentioned
insect colony behavior different kinds
of problems
and we also have results in the past two
years on brain networks we studied
problems called winner-take-all which is
for us a kind of leader election problem
singling out one neuron similarity
detection problem and some coding
problems
so more specifically to brain algorithms
our goal is to understand how
computation is performed in biological
neural networks in terms of distributed
algorithms using distributed algorithms
methods so the features that we're
modeling in our work are spiking neurons
we use noisy firing thresholds we take
into account excitation and inhibition
restricted connectivity synapse weights
synchronization of course that's not
everything so far we focused on fixed
networks rather than on learning the
networks so we certainly are interested
in learning in terms of say adjusting
weights but right now we're just looking
at the question of what networks are the
best ones to solve certain problems that
might arise in the brain so the problems
we look at are actually abstractions of
real problems for example you might want
to select one neuron from a set of
firing neurons or you might want to test
similarity of input patterns or neural
coding data compression so these are
abstract problems that are the kinds of
things that occur in the brain but it's
not trying to directly model in full
detail a particular brain operation so
these are basic abstract computational
primitives rather than complex
real-world problems
so the questions that we ask are well
how do the the features of the model
that are derived from biology affect the
solvability of particular problems so we
can study whether problems are solvable
or not and at what cost in terms of the
models so what's the impact of the
different kinds of biological features
on solvability results and on the costs
of solving the problems and what kinds
of algorithms would you design with
these different types of biologically
inspired models the theoretical side is
there some interesting new theory beyond
what's already been studied in
computational models for biology people
have studied deterministic threshold
circuit Boltzmann machines on the
distributed computing side distributed
graph networks so we're interested
certainly at whether this interesting
new theory here but does this theory say
anything interesting about computation
in real neural networks so for example
the kinds of issues that have come up in
our algorithms are interesting uses ways
of coping with noise interesting uses
for randomness roll the roll of
inhibition and excitation identifying
patterns that appear in solutions to
many problems so these are the kinds of
things that could mean something for
real neural networks the starting point
a couple of years ago with some papers
that we read by both come on the theory
of spiking neural networks okay so I'll
start right in and describe our model
and please just ask questions since you
know I'm used to speaking a different
kind of language from you guys so okay
if something doesn't make sense
okay so we're this is a stochastic
spiking neural network model so this is
supposed to represent discrete time
slots so this is different from a lot of
what we've heard today where you're
talking about continuous time since
brain networks certainly have a strong
notion of
we're abstracting and on the discrete
side to have synchronized rounds of
computation so the notation is just
saying that neuron V spikes at time T we
just say B at V Super T equals one it's
not spiking at time T plus two
so then the picture is any particular
neuron has other neurons that are have
incoming edges to it and then those
edges have weights on them and so you
calculate at each round a potential for
the burner on V by adding up the
potentials of all its incoming neighbors
that happen to be firing should be
common oh and we're subtracting a bias
or threshold that's particular to the
neuron and then what we do with this is
use a sigmoid function and instead of
looking at a deterministic threshold for
firing we use the sigmoid to give us a
probability of firing okay so we have a
noisy threshold model or stochastic
model
okay so we also model inhibitory and
excitatory neurons and that just means
that the weights that are outgoing from
the neuron are either all positive or
all negative in the hibbett ori case and
we're not doing anything at least not
yet with a lot of other biological
features that ought to be interesting
like refractory periods spike
propagation delays history so any ones
of memory we want to model that and
we're starting to do some work on that
but nothing yet we haven't modeled noise
on synapses but I think that could be
basically absorbed into the noise that
we get at the at the neurons but we'll
see okay all right so the neural network
model is it's a weighted directed graph
the nodes are the neurons the edges are
the synapses are our connections between
the neurons and the weights are synaptic
strength so it's just a technicality if
the weight is zero that's the same as
not having an edge at all weight is
positive it's excitatory weight is
negative it's an inhibitory edge so
we're taking a complicated cell with its
in APS's well here's just a single
synapse and modeling that by an abstract
edge and an entire brain network is
modeled by a directed graph just ask
questions if something doesn't
all right so okay in the problems we're
looking at we're saying the neurons in a
network are either input neurons the X
neurons or output neurons the Y's or
hidden or auxiliary neurons which I've
written here is a okay and just as a
technicality the input and output
neurons are excitatory but the auxiliary
neurons can be anything excitatory
inhibitory they're just the part of the
design of the network so whatever kinds
of neurons you need for designing the
network use them there all right so how
does the network operate it's probably
already pretty obvious at a particular
moment in time well maybe it's not
obvious because this is discrete-time so
two particular discrete-time you have a
firing state for each neuron it's either
firing or not so zero or one one if it's
firing and then how the way this
operates is it goes through what we call
an execution so it's a sequence of
configurations at each each
configuration is obtained from the
previous one by letting everybody fire
according to the network dynamics so UT
is the firing state of neuron U at time
T so since this is supposed to represent
a component in a system as inputs and
outputs the inputs are assumed to come
from the outside world we don't say what
they are for this this subsystem so in
terms of the modelling the input firing
patterns are arbitrary so the network
has to be able to handle all kinds of
inputs but the initial firing patterns
for all the internal the auxiliary in
the output neurons are part of the
network definition they say how it's
initialized okay so what happened so you
have this network and then you have to
say what's the input for any particular
infinite input executions so this is
modeling what's happening
throughout time the network is going to
produce not a particular output
execution but a probability distribution
on executions right so you basically
applied the stochastic firing dynamics
for all the neurons at all the rounds
and this winds you up with a probability
distribution on executions of the system
yeah so this is going to be an arbitrary
directed graph well technically the
inputs should not have any edges going
to them from inside the graph because
they're supposed to be produced by
someone else but everything else can
provide input to anything else
well we haven't thought about
distributions it could we could do that
but we just either say you start in a
particular state or you start an
arbitrary state so for instance looking
ahead a little bit in some of our
problems we want it to converge to a
certain kind of state and we might want
that no matter what state had started in
so then we could say that the network
has as an arbitrary start starting
configuration
excuse me you have the current state UT
depends on the current state this is no
no no so this isn't saying how the the
dynamics are determined this is just
giving notation for the firing state of
T being just what's in the configuration
T configuration T is a mapping from
neurons to firing states so this is just
saying UT which is going to be either
firing or not is whatever configuration
T says for you yeah it's a mapping
configurations assigns a firing state to
every neuron so we say C of U is 1 if
it's firing so this is like C CT of U is
1 if u is firing at time T yeah right so
what I showed on the on the earlier
slide about the dynamics and the sigmoid
function that's how you determine but
it's stochastic yeah the impact of the
spike is only at the next time step
right that's right it's such a time step
very tiny we're thinking of postsynaptic
potential last 20 so we may need
different time scales for different
activity yeah
for us to get started coming from where
we were we had to fix a certain model
and try to get some basic results to try
to show show people you know the kinds
of things we want to do but what we can
certainly see is is that you want to
generalize this model in all sorts of
different directions and it probably
will give you different kinds of results
my hope is that people may be interested
enough to maybe suggest some variations
on it which could lead to new insights
about
this is for every infinite input
execution is it the output is also
clamped right input output execution you
know for every every input execution so
that's you specify what's gonna come in
on all the input neurons for in forever
and that will cause you to generate the
behavior of the whole system forever but
stochastic yeah right the auxiliary and
output neurons I'm sorry that's this is
okay so produces a probability
distribution on infinite executions the
execution includes all the neurons we
already know what happens to the inputs
because that that's given to us by
someone else but the system's stochastic
the dynamics are going to determine what
happens to all the internal and the
output neurons I'm not sure exactly so
with the stochastic
so alright so the way we play games and
distributed computing theory is you have
a model this is a distributed system
model and then you describe some
problems you'd like to solve so what's a
problem in this setting okay well let's
say you have some collection of input
neurons and you have some collection of
output neurons and in the special case
that happens to cover the problems we've
done so far it's kind of simple you
start out with fixed behavior of all the
input neurons like they're just stuck at
some value forever think of it is for a
long time okay and so what you would
like to do is compute some function but
since this is probabilistic it isn't
going to be an actual function it could
be a multi valued function with certain
with different probabilities for
different outputs so the problem is
going to be cast as a mapping from the
input neuron firing patterns to the
output neuron firing pattern the
probability distribution on output
neuron firing patterns well okay so no
in this in this case we're talking about
a set of possible firing patterns
without the probability and the goal is
to design a network that's going to
converge to one of the allowed output
patterns so we could also in the more
general notion of problem that we use
includes the probability for which
output you produce but I just put
something simpler here a set of
allowable outputs and you have to
produce one of them it's supposed to be
a small network we're trying to measure
the size of the network is one of our
costs of interest and we'd like it to
converge rapidly to an output that's
allowed by this function problem
definition
but of course that can't be absolute
it's going to be with some high
probability okay so the complexity
measures I already indicated there'll be
some static measures like the size of
the network the number of neurons a
number of auxiliary neurons perhaps
number of inhibitors the maximum size of
the weights that you use anything that's
just a property of the network itself
but you also want dynamic measures like
how long does it take to converge and
how long do you remain in your converged
State as well okay so I'll spend most of
the time and the rest of the talk
describing our work on one problem
winner-take-all and I don't think I'll
have time to get into this so I may just
flash some slides quickly there okay the
winner-take-all problem so we presented
this in itcs that's innovations in
theoretical computer science last year
so this is something that we got from
reading a bunch of neuroscience papers
so the winner-take-all problem as n
inputs and they're either always firing
or always not firing simple case this is
a binary version of the winner-take-all
problem the neuro neuroscience
literature has with different rates for
the firing working we're studying that
now but simple cases just they're firing
or not and each of the inputs has a
corresponding output neuron okay and so
what we would like is no matter what
state you begin this network in that
that's the all the internal and the
output neurons no matter what's the
firing state they start in we'd like
high probability and we measure that
with probability at least 1 minus some
parameter Delta the network should
converge within a time T sub C and we
think of that as short because they'd
like it to converge fast to where
there's only one firing output and
moreover it should be one of those a
cars
to a firing input so you're basically
electing a leader from among the
candidates and then we would like it to
remain stable with only that one neuron
firing and we can't say that it's going
to happen forever but with high
probability it should stay stable for a
long time this is from our point of view
a neural version of a leader election
problem as we study leader election
problems in other settings on the
neuroscience side you probably how many
people know it from papers in your area
it seems to be used in attention focus
competitive learning problems and it's
been described by Wolfgang is a
nonlinear primitive meaning I guess that
you can't that it adds extra power to
standard linear threshold circuits okay
so here's what a solution looks like
it's very simple and we're not saying
this is what happens in the brain but
you know it could be and maybe some of
these mechanisms would be things that
people could look for to see if things
like that occur I don't know so this
basically has two inhibitors playing
different roles you have a one inhibitor
that we call this stability inhibitor
now it's going to try to keep things
stable once they've reached a good state
so what it does is it fires with high
probability whenever there's at least
one output firing one or more and what
does this do well it prevents outputs
that if there's one output firing it
present prevents other outputs that
didn't fire at time t from firing at the
next time T plus 1 it's got it has
enough inhibition to prevent other
neurons from starting up if they're not
firing already but before you've gotten
to the state where one just one guy is
firing we are using a convergence
inhibitor the other inhibitor fires with
high probability whenever two or more
outputs are firing so what this does is
it causes any output that fires a time T
to fire at time T plus one only with
probability
1/2 okay so you're introducing some
stochastic behavior with this second
convergence and inhibitor it's trying to
drive the network to the point where
there's there's fewer neurons firing
yeah they're all turned all the outputs
are turned off well you you still have a
probability of 1/2 of neurons starting
to fire so I'm gonna say a bit about the
proof so you can see I guess that what
some of the reasoning is okay so the
idea is if there's a lot of outputs that
are firing about half of them are going
to stop firing at each step so with
logarithmic behavior this is going to
get down to only one firing so with some
constant probability there's a time
that's at most log in where exactly one
output is firing at time T the general
idea Morath but moreover after that
convergence time with high probability
this output will continue to fire for a
long time that's TS and while that's
happening only inhibitor a s the
stability inhibitor is firing which is
preventing other outputs from starting
to fire you already have one firing
so the thresholds have to be set in a
way that the the inhibitors only fire at
the at the right threshold so that
wasn't the whole solution here I'm
filling in all the other weights on the
edges that you need to make this work so
the output neurons have a bias of 3 the
weights of the edges from inputs to
outputs are 3 the weights of the self
loops are only 2 so they help each other
they help themselves to continue firing
once they are but their bias is 3 so
they need to get something else the
weights of the edges from the outputs to
the both inhibitors are 1 and the
weights from the inhibitors to the
outputs or minus 1 okay so we prove an
actual theorem in our style so assuming
that did I
I skipped a slide all right there's one
more thing which is we're putting a
weighting factor in I wrote the numbers
as if they're just simple 35.5 etcetera
but they actually have to be weighted by
a factor gamma okay
oh somehow a diagram didn't appear all
right well here's the diagram again okay
so you assume that gamma is large enough
and so then what we can prove is
starting from any state with probability
1 minus Delta the network is going to
converge with in time the convergence
time is about C log n there's also this
other factor of log 1 over Delta it's
going to take longer if you need a
higher probability of the succeeding mmm
so it converges within this time and
remain stable for the time TS ok so we
also get some other results around this
there's an expected time bound then we
can show that you can do better than
this if you use more inhibitors you can
get faster convergence and then we
explore well could you solve the problem
faster with two inhibitors and we
actually do something that you might not
have seen in neuroscience to prove look
impossibility results or lower bounds
let's say that you can't solve the
problem much faster with a certain
number of inhibitors so you can't solve
it much faster than our solution with
just two inhibitors and in fact you
can't solve it at all you could ask a
theoretical question what if you only
had one inhibitor and it turns out she
simply can't solve this problem and you
can prove that
okay so alright how do you so we have
our r2 in him yeah so is it for example
clustering the input space pedal in the
output corresponds to roughly the same
amount of input pedals so what you mean
is there fairness like in who you choose
this actually would well you mean which
who is going to be chosen because of the
symmetry in the solution it's going to
be equally likely to be any of them
because they behave completely
symmetrically it happens we know if you
have let's say all the input neurons are
firing you'll have like one over n
chance of producing each one of them
it's not a high likelihood of any
particular one so alright how do you
analyze something like this so we're
using some proof techniques from
distributed computing theory and I'm
gonna have to watch the time aren't I
have what what okay so we have to show
with high probability that it converges
the system is going to reach a valid
configuration WT a configuration and
stability it should say once it reaches
there it should stay there for a long
time now
these are reminiscent of the kinds of
properties we prove all the time in for
distributed algorithms so we're kind of
following the style that we've used for
a long time
stability properties are common and we
prove them using invariance they
basically say if you're in a certain
type of configuration any step you do is
going to keep you in that configuration
convergence properties approved by
showing progress through a series of
milestones where you get closer and
closer to the region and the similar
kinds of arguments in control theory for
continuous systems
okay twist now is that we want high
probability statements rather than
absolute statements so things get a
little more complicated so for example
the stability proof I'll just give you
the flavor of it okay a valid WTA
configuration sure that's one where
there's exactly one output firing and
it's one that corresponds to a firing
input but you also want the inhibitors
to be doing the right thing so in the
stable states the stability inhibitor
should be firing but the convergence
inhibitor should not be firing okay so
you have the basically the state of the
entire system specified if you have all
of this then with high probability the
next configuration is going to be
identical so that says that this is
stable and if it's high probably enough
probability that it's identical but that
will tell you that this persists for a
long time and you can quantify all that
persist with high probability okay all
right so how do you prove stability all
right the style for invariance would
basically just say what's guaranteed by
a single step so you suppose you're in
some configuration and it leads to a new
configuration that's probabilistic then
with high probability well this first
thing is just a simple observation you
never get an output firing that
corresponds to a non firing input so
once you're no matter what configuration
you're in you're very unlikely to be
able to have some output start firing if
it's input wasn't firing a little more
interesting is if you have only the
stability inhibitor firing in this
configuration then all the same outputs
fire that fired in the previous one okay
so it's not just if there's only one
firing no matter what outputs were
firing and configuration see if just the
stability inhibitors firing is keeping
things the same so the same outputs are
going to be firing in C prime that were
in C
with high probability okay
also if there's exactly one firing
output in C then you can say that in the
next configuration the stability neuron
is firing but the convergence neuron is
no longer firing so you have a bunch of
facts like this and you can kind of see
you put them together and you can show
stability of good configuration that
would configuration convergence to prove
that things get a little harder because
you're talking about multi-step behavior
not just what's happening and in one
step so all right so this is like
proving progress properties and
distributed computing by going through a
series of milestones so this is just a
depiction of well you're starting to
accomplish something and you might be
resetting to a start state and maybe you
have in neurons firing and you go down
for a while to some smaller and smaller
number and then you get to a near valid
state technically different from a valid
stage and then if you're lucky you go to
the valid state and most of these steps
except for this last one all the other
steps are happening with high
probability so there's this little
technicality in this last step there's
some race conditions going on so you
could skip from a state where two or
more neurons are firing to one where no
neurons are firing it's not all that
unlikely all right I mean you'd like to
say you know nicely you have the number
of neurons that are firing at each state
but of course this is all probabilistic
and you might not so you could go from
more than two all the way down to zero
another thing that could go wrong is at
the point where you single out as one
firing output you still have two two
inhibitors firing it takes a little time
like one more round to shut down one of
them and if they're both firing then
there's a chance that the one output
that's firing is then going to stop okay
so there's a little race condition
but the outcome of this is that you
still have constant probability I just
like 118th or something of succeeding
and if not well the proof basically
starts over you have to start allowing
more outputs to the network starts
allowing more outputs to fire and then
has to do this several times I don't
know if that kind of thing occurs
biologically or maybe there's something
that gets rid of these race conditions
okay so we have our convergence lemma
the probability of reaching a WTA
configuration is at least a constant and
that leads to the theorem that says that
you solve the the problem because you
have both the convergence and the
stability limits that's how we can
analyze this all right so the rest of
this is you get a faster solution with
more inhibitors so you still use one
stability inhibitor but now let's say
you use a lot more convergence
inhibitors to try to help you get to
where there's only one firing let's say
that they have larger and larger biases
so they're trying to detect when more
and more outputs are firing and these
extra inhibitors are going to speed up
the convergence when you have a lot of
firing outputs because the higher bias
inhibitors are going to trigger when
more outputs are firing and the effect
is that they go they're going to
decrease the probability of continuing
to fire so instead of just half you
might get down to like 1 over N if this
if everybody's firing you'd like the
probability to you know make it close to
like high probability that only one will
be firing at the very next round rather
than having to cut it down by a half at
each round so we can play games like
that and you get a theorem and now this
is like the K through tough log n
instead of log n in the bound
all right and then we prove lower bounds
so we have to put four lower bounds are
very hard to prove and sometimes you
have to pin down a few more assumptions
on the model which we did in this case
so we have to say the inputs are only
connected to their own outputs and the
outputs aren't connected to each other
and the exhilerating are now are all
inhibitors that isn't necessary we could
we can generalize that but these are
conditions that are satisfied by our
algorithms and the proofs use something
that we would call locality arguments
they're used all over the place to prove
impossibility and distributed algorithms
because I mean the basic limitation of
distributed computing is nobody knows
what's happening globally they only know
what they can see so that limitation
leads to many kinds of impossibility
results okay so for an easy result
suppose you just have one inhibitor
there's no network then with just one
inhibitor that can solve the problem
with stability time that's bigger than
the convergence time quantify all that
but I'll just give you the idea suppose
what would happen if you had a WT a
network with just one inhibitor okay
well then what happens is only two
possibilities that are round this guy's
firing or he's not okay if he's not
firing and you can show that the outputs
that correspond to firing inputs had
better have a good probability of firing
because if there's no inhibition going
on I mean how would it even get started
how would you get any outputs to fire
when you're starting the network up so
you need to ensure that at least output
will fire in time and so it has to be
that an output with a firing input has
to have good probability of firing the
other case though if a is firing well
then you'd like it to be that any output
that was firing at the last round needs
a good probability of stopping because
you need the capability of reducing the
number of firing outputs I mean no
is not a formal proof but the thing is
that you have a combinations only two
cases its firing or it's not and neither
one of these is good for stability it's
uh it's firing it's been even if there's
only one guy firing what do you like
he's gonna have good probability of
stopping and the same kind of problem in
the other case okay and you can also
prove that you can't improve our
solution by more than log log n factor
okay and the idea is just that fast
convergence requires a lot of inhibition
when there are many outputs firing but
this inhibition is too high when there's
only a few outputs firing and that's not
giving you a whole lot of intuition but
basically with only two neurons there's
only basically three levels of
inhibition that you can have and that's
not enough to draw all the distinctions
that you need okay so discussion part
four this is just notice that we had
some interesting use of inhibition there
the inhibitors are used for two purposes
stability and convergence so you know
I've seen many places where inhibition
is is viewed as a stability mechanism in
the brain but we see that it can also be
used to drive the computation toward
convergence and the other interesting
feature is randomness
so yeah it's a source of noise but it
can also be used for something it's a
computational resource and in this case
it's used to break symmetry among the
output neurons okay so I don't think I
have time to do anything else through so
our other problem is on similarity
testing if you have to input firing
patterns you want to distinguish the
case where they're equal from the case
where they're significantly different
okay and this is doing a testing so
there's one neuron that's basically
going to output the answer say are they
very similar or not so this is a kind of
thing that that should appear in pattern
recognizer
and tasks so basically we came up with
an idea for an algorithm that comes
straight out of the complexity theory
it's a simple sampling algorithm if you
want to know if these two things are
close to each other you can sample a
certain number of random positions and
check whether the two vectors match at
these positions well if the two vectors
match then your sample is going to match
but if they're significantly different
then you'll have a probability high
enough probability by doing the sampling
of noticing that they're different so
basically just doing us a sampling
solution to determine if things are
different and yeah so all right so I'll
just say how we implement this the
Equality check between the sample
vectors is simple but then how do you
actually do the the sampling and here we
use a an indexing module which may not
be very brain like it's not a
biologically it wasn't designed with any
biological inspiration it's just a way
of extracting the same the neuron in the
same position in the two vectors so I
think because of time I'm going to just
skip through there's a picture of how
you put the pieces together for the
similarity testing
water balance okay another use of
randomness now for random sampling which
seems to be useful in the brain for
compression abstraction and comparison
okay so as a final remark I just wanted
to talk about how we can compose we're
interested in composing little
subproblems so first going to solve
little abstract problems in the brain
how do you put them together to solve
more interesting complex problems so
this is one example from the the using
indexing to do the similarity testing
but there's several others which like
using WTA to solve some problem of
focusing on a particular series of
inputs and you can have composition
that's
this is weird
all right
well there's layered composition and
composition with feedback and this slide
looked fine a few minutes ago
okay so composing spiking neural
networks we're following again some
paradigms from concurrency theory to try
to develop some math foundations for
composing these networks to basically
define the behavior of a network as it
did before define the problems that the
networks are solving and then you have
results like if you compose two networks
and you compose two problems well if
this network solves that problem and
this Network solves that one then the
composition of the networks should solve
that a combined problem this is just
very basic concurrency theory okay so
this is our goal and some of the
progress we've made and there's some
interesting issues have arisen and they
may or may not say something about
biology but we hope so
[Applause]
ran so over time think of it spiky new
assembly is active or not and maybe if
it's active it's 450 milliseconds or so
and then only the next 50 millisecond it
programs which other ones okay I think
we would need to augment the model with
some history which is something we're
doing in another paper we're working on
now but yeah then we'd be able to
remember so you could schedule went it
happy delayed effect
so Cameron one of the authors is now
writing up what was in the very short
itcs paper into it's now like 70 pages
it's a thesis long thesis chapter so
this is sort of showing how the modeling
works and not the proofs and all that so
it could be a good model for someone
else - yeah it's an interesting question
the the continuous systems are really
what we have here is really what you
call a hybrid system it's a combination
of continuous and discrete so there's
there's a whole area of hybrid systems
basically you might regard these as some
kind of approximation to a continuous
system sometimes you're able to analyze
a continuous system and then prove a
connection between the discrete and
there they're not so far apart various
people have worked on that that sort of
approach we haven't done it in this yeah
it's like we not take all for instance
either asynchronous separate or delays
the department that you're working with
might be the tastic later because it's
not the case that all the neurons are
going to be seeing the same important in
so one you know the way you you get out
of notes and hopfield network it's just
by asynchronous wiring things like that
might change it could we were kind of
thinking that the synchrony kind of
reflects the fact that the brain has
pretty good control of timing we didn't
want to make it we didn't want to
consider completely asynchronous systems
here because that's just too pessimistic
I think for brain modeling
are you worried that it's the
distribution over hidden typically could
be very highly multimodal right here you
have two neurons for the Linear Tape I
don't know how many girls we have for
their similarity I don't know if hands
like square root of antlers I think root
of n yeah I guess we'd have to see what
happens when we try to analyze it I mean
we're doing some pretty simple things
here these are very these are not like
trying to look at you know solving some
hard brain problem that's just
[Applause]